[Applaudissements]
des scènes qu'on n'avait pas vu depuis
des mois au centre ville de hong kong
des milliers de manifestants
pro-démocratie aspergé de gaz
lacrymogène par la police
visiblement le mouvement qui semblait
être tout fait dans le contexte de la
pandémie ne l'est pas ce qui a mis de
l'huile sur le feu c'est la décision de
la chine n'est posée à hong kong une loi
sur la sécurité nationale la loi
empêcherait toute contestation du
gouvernement et permettrait aux services
chinois de sécurité d'intervenir
directement sur place les militants pro
démocratie dénonce une des pires
attaques menées contre l'autonomie de
l'ancienne colonie britannique et de son
principe un pays deux systèmes hong
offrit société franck ribéry mais on
cogne restera une société libre assure
la chef de l'exécutif car il en va
il ya deux jours la proposition a
entraîné l'évacuation d'un membre du
parlement de hong kong des législateurs
pro-démocratie craignent le pire
sont ils entrés nous dire qu'il y aura
une organisation ou du sud et loi si
c'est le cas ce sera la fin de hong kong
selon la police 120 personnes auraient
été arrêtées lors des manifestations
dont cet homme ici gabriel proulx radio
canada montréal